problema número 167 si uno más uno entre
equis es igual a 2 - 2 entre equis cuál
es el valor de x lo primero que voy a
hacer es quitar esas x de los
denominadores multiplicando ambos lados
por x me va a quedar x más uno es igual
2 x menos 2
estamos x en ambos lados me va a quedar
uno igual a x menos 2 y sumamos 2 en
ambos lados por lo que me queda 3 igual
a x que es la opción
sí o siguiente problema problema número
168 el año pasado de cada 100 millones
de vehículos que circularon por una
avenida 96 estuvieron involucrados en
accidentes si 3.000 millones de autos
circularon por esa avenida el año pasado
cuántos estuvieron involucrados en
accidentes los autos que estuvieron
involucrados en accidentes fueron 96 de
un total de 100 millones
es cien por diez a las seis un millón es
un uno seguido de seis ceros podemos ver
esto como la fracción de accidentes así
que vamos a multiplicar esto por el
total esto lo multiplicamos por 3 mil
millones mil millones es un 1 seguido de
90 3 por 10 a la 9 vamos a simplificarlo
esto de aquí este denominador lo puedo
dejar como
estos dos ceros los incluyo aquí en el
exponente y me queda 1 por 10 a la 81
por 10 a la 8 este por 10 a la 9 entre
él por 10 a 8 éste se va y aquí en
además me va a quedar 3 por 10 por lo
que esto es igual a 96 por 30
96 por 30 es 2.880 2.880 autos
involucrados en accidentes que es la
opción si siguiente problema problema
número 169 30% de los miembros de un
club de natación pasaron la prueba de
salvavidas de los miembros que no
aprobaron 12 tomaron el curso
preparatorio y 30 no tomaron el curso
cuántos miembros tiene el club de
natación los datos son 30 por ciento que
aprobaron aprobaron
70% por lo tanto el resto no aprobaron
y aprobaron
12 tomaron el curso
no tomaron el curso
asumimos que el total de los que no
aprobaron son estos 230 + 12 el total de
los que no aprobaron son 42 s es el 70%
así que el 70% del total es igual a 42
por lo tanto el total si divido todo
entre puntos 7 va a ser igual a 42
en 3.76 por 742 pero como es punto 7
esto va a ser igual a 60 y el 60% de 70
es 42 esto tiene sentido así que mi
total son 60 integrantes que es la
opción a siguiente problema número 170
en cierta compañía la proporción del
número de administradores con respecto
al número de trabajadores de producción
es de 5 a 72 si se van a contratar 8
trabajadores de producción la proporción
ahora será de 5 a 74 cuántos
administradores tiene la compañía los
administradores con respecto a los
trabajadores de producción la proporción
es de 5 a 72
después nos dicen que contratan a 8
trabajadores de producción más serán
productores que hay más 8 y ahora la
proporción cambia de 5 a 74 hay dos
maneras de pensar en ello un método
rápido y uno algebraico vamos a hacer
los dos si observamos esto al agregar
ocho en la producción
la proporción sólo aumentó en dos y lo
que probablemente está pasando es que
tenemos cuatro veces más trabajadores en
esta proporción así que probablemente
sea igual a 20 administradores entre 288
trabajadores de producción multiplicamos
todos estos dos lados por cuatro y si le
agregamos ocho aquí en el denominador
esto más ocho va a ser igual a 20 entre
296 y esto así lo dividimos entre 4 nos
da esta proporción 5 a 74 esto nos da la
proporción de 5
entre 74 lo que es correcto pero si no
tienen esta intuición rápida de captar
este concepto y esta proporción vamos a
resolverlo de manera algebraica así que
no se preocupen esto de aquí es igual a
5 por produce producción igual a 72
y hacemos la multiplicación cruzada
entre más 85 entre 74 así que tenemos 5
p
+ 40 es igual a 74
qué es esto esta otra porción está de
aquí a esta proporción le vamos a restar
esta otra menos 5 p igual a menos 72
porque estoy restando 72
me queda que esto se va aquí hay 40 74
72 es 2a el número de administradores va
a ser igual a 40 entre 2 por lo que será
igual a 2020 es el número que habíamos
encontrado aquí con nuestra intuición
llegamos al mismo resultado a cabo ya
quizás este otro método algebraico sea
más fácil de entender pero bueno pasemos
al siguiente problema problema número
171 si x menos 1 al cuadrado es igual a
400 cuál de los siguientes es un posible
valor de x menos 5
x menos 1
sacamos raíz cuadrada de estos dos lados
me va a quedar que x menos uno es igual
a 20
20 x 20 400 o que x uno puede decir
igual a menos 20 menos 20 x menos 20 es
igual a 400 ambos me dan este resultado
así que x en este caso puede ser igual a
si sumamos 1 en ambos lados va a ser
igual a 21 y en este caso x si sumamos 1
en ambos lados me va a quedar menos 20
más uno menos 19 esos son los posibles
valores de x nos preguntan x 5 así que
en este caso x menos 5 si tomamos este
valor será 21 menos 5 igual a 16
en este caso x 5 con esta x es igual a
menos 19 menos 5 va a ser igual a menos
24 y esta última es la opción c
aquí no hay que olvidar que la raíz
cuadrada también puede ser negativa
bueno pasemos al siguiente problema
número 172 vuelve a los siguientes y
escribe todos los posibles valores de x
para los cuales 1 - x cuadrada es mayor
o igual a 0 sumamos x cuadrado en ambos
lados y nos va a quedar 1 mayor o igual
que x cuadrada y lo cambio lo voy a
invertir porque así como que lo entiendo
mejor x cuadrada va a ser menor
menor o igual que 1x está al cuadrado y
sabemos que al trabajar con números
reales x será un número positivo pero
aquí nos dicen que es menor o igual a 1
o puede ser mayor
igual que menos 1 ya que ambos números
al elevarse al cuadrado van a ser
menores o iguales a 1 por lo tanto menos
es si x es mayor o igual a menos 1 y en
la vez es menor o igual a 1 y ustedes
hagan la prueba si no me creen para que
vean que cualquier valor de x que se
encuentra en este rango al elevarse al
cuadrado va a ser menor o igual a 1 el 0
también lo cumple y esta es mi opción
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo